[Music]
it's 2018 and we are kicking off the
year right because Jota is officially
the co-anchor of today it's official
Hoda Kotb is permanently taking Matt
Lauer's spot on The Today Show I've been
filling in for the last three or four
weeks and first it was you know can you
fill in for a week and it was and I
happily did it and then they said well
how about next week and then how about
the week after and then something
happened and it was so weird there
wasn't like a magic moment it just
worked do you know what I mean how about
forever Ichi was on set with Hoda and
co-anchor Savannah Guthrie right after
the exciting announcement was made
Tuesday morning this has been a very
hard time for this show that we love and
having Hoda right with me every second
of the way has meant everything and we
kind of held on to each other and then
discover it along the way that there's a
real partnership here and I think that
that's what makes it work this is a show
that we love and pour our heart and soul
into I think we're the balance potes
promotion comes at just weeks after Matt
Lauer was ousted from the morning show
following a series of sexual misconduct
allegations both Hoda and Savannah tell
et they're still in contact with their
former colleague he texted me and he
said congratulations and some really
nice words and it meant the world when I
saw the text pop up my heart just like
you know it meant the world to see that
of course we keep in touch you know Matt
is our good friend and continues to be
and you know I think for both of us
we've been just trying to navigate this
time and honor our love and friendship
with Matt but also you know understand
and try to learn more about you know
these circumstances we're just trying to
navigate all of that with
straightforwardness and honesty and
integrity
[Music]
you